arms to stay on Friday I know that
colleagues from across the house will
want to join me in Remembering those who
have lost their lives in the service of
our country
Mr Speaker
had meetings with ministerial colleagues
and others in addition to my duties in
this house I shall have further such
meetings later today Bill Coyle thank
you Mr Speaker the people I serve will
of course be commemorative remembrance
Burma Z was the original home of the
poppy Factory providing work for injured
veterans of the Great War over 100 years
ago but Mr Speaker covid restrictions
were a necessary if painful experience
across the country most people made
enormous sacrifices like Charlotte my
constituents and local Council Lorraine
unable to see their mums in their final
days these people were betrayed by the
conservatives who parted their way
through lockdown
[Applause]
[Music]
you may not like it but you can all go
to eat kangaroo testicles where I like
it but those
uncertainties
[Music]
and in fixed penalty notices can this
prime minister promise today he will use
his power veto to ensure that no one who
received an fpn for breaking covered
laws is rewarded with a seat in the
House of Lords
well Mr Mr Speaker what I can say is
that this government during covid ensure
that we protected people's jobs
who we supported the NHS to get through
the difficult times and that we rolled
out the fastest vaccine in Europe that's
what we did for this country
[Applause]
thank you Mr Mexico welcome the
commitments made by my writable friend
at the cop27 this week if he wants to do
something that really helps get us to
Net Zero improves our energy security
and helps create new opportunities in
places like Milford Haven South Wales
Southwest England collect urchin to
really throw the full weight of his
office behind delivering floating
offshore wind in the Celtic Sea and
crucially ensure that decisions being
taken now by the crown estate and the
treasury mean that the economic value
the jobs of this new industry stay here
in the UK
well can I praise my right normal friend
for highlighting the incredible
potential of floating offshore wind
technology to help us move to Net Zero
he's right about the opportunities in
the Celtic Sea and for Wales more
generally and I can confirm to him that
Crown estate's leasing process is
expected to deliver more seabed leases
for many more projects
[Applause]
speaker can I join the Prime Minister
and his comments about Remembrance Day
we remember all those who paid the
ultimate price and all those who have
served and are serving our country
Mr Speaker the member for South
Staffordshire told a civil servant to
Slit their throat
how does the Prime Minister think the
victim of that bullying felt when he
expressed great sagness at his
resignation
unequivocally the behavior complained of
was unacceptable and it is absolutely
right it is absolutely right that the
right honorable gentleman has resigned
for the record I did not know about any
of the specific concerns relating to his
conduct as Secretary of State or chief
whip which date back some years I
believe that people in public life
should treat others with consideration
and respect and those other principles
that this government will stand by
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the member for South
Staffordshire spent years courting the
idea he can intimidate others blurring
the lines to normalize bullying Behavior
it's precisely why the Prime Minister
gave him a job the truth is simple he's
a pathetic bully but he would never get
away with it if people like the Prime
Minister didn't hand him power
[Applause]
so does he regret his decision to make
him a government minister
Mr Speaker I obviously regret appointing
someone who has had to resign in these
circumstances
but I think
sanctions like this arise that they will
be dealt with properly
he writes that there is an investigation
to look into these matters properly I
said my government would be
characterized by Integrity
professionalism and account visibility
and it will
[Applause]
Mr Speaker everyone in the country knows
someone like the member for South
Staffordshire a sad middle manager
getting off on intimidating those
beneath them but everyone in the country
also knows someone like the Prime
Minister the boss who is so weak so
worried the bullies will turn on him
that he hides behind them
what message does he think it sends when
rather than take on the bullies he lines
up alongside them and thanks them for
their loyalty
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the message that I clearly
want to send is that Integrity in public
life matters and that is why that is why
it is right that the right honorable
member has resigned it is why it is
right that there is a rigorous process
to examine these issues
as well as focusing on this one
individual it is also right and
important that we keep delivering for
the whole country and that's why this
government will continue to concentrate
on stabilizing the economy on
strengthening the NHS and or tackling
illegal migration those are my
priorities those are the priorities of
the British people and this government
will deliver on them
stoma
Mr Speaker the problem is he can't stand
up to a run-of-the-mill bully yeah so he
has no chance of standing up to vested
interests on behalf of working people
take shell they made record profits this
year 26 billion pounds how much have
they paid under his so-called windfall
tax
Mr Speaker I was Chancellor who
introduced an extra attack on the oil
and gas companies right but but he talks
he talks Mr Speaker he talks about
working people the right honorable
member
of corrupting working people
he voted he voted against legislation to
stop extremist protesters disrupting
working people that's because he's not
on the side of working people Mr Speaker
that's what the conservatives are for
Mr Speaker I'm against all of those
causing chaos damage to our Public
Services into our economy whether they
are gluing themselves to the road or
sitting on the government benches Mr
Speaker there was no answer to the
question because the answer is nothing
shall haven't paid a penny in winful tax
why because for every pound they spend
digging for fossil fuels he hands them a
90p tax break and it's costing the
taxpayer billions so will he find a
backbone an end is absurd oil and gas
giveaway
[Applause]
oh Mr Speaker what the party opposite
will never understand is that its
businesses investing that create jobs in
this country
with Mr Speaker we on this side of the
house we understand that we will support
businesses to invest to create jobs
because that's how we create Prosperity
that's how we support strong public
services and that's what you get with a
conservative government
[Applause]
there's only one party that crashed the
economy and they're all sitting there
it's a pattern Mr Speaker it's a pattern
with this prime minister too weak to
sack the security threat sat around the
cabinet table too weak to take part in a
leadership contest after he lost the
first one too weak to stand up for
working people
spent weeks flirting with the climate
change deniers in his party then
scuffled off to cop at the last minute
yes in the budget next week he'll be too
weak to end his oil and gas giveaway
scrap the non-dom tax breaks and end the
fast of taxpayers subsidizing private
schools that's what labor would do a
proper plan for working people
[Applause]
stand up to a cartoon bully with a pet
spider
to face the public in an election what
chances he got of running the country
foreign
get through on time and I know some
members want to catch my eye they're not
doing a good job so far come on prime
minister
Mr Speaker there are a gentleman talks
about judgment about putting people
around the cabinet table I would just
generally remind him he thought the
member for Islington North but surround
security
but Mr Speaker The Honorable gentleman
The Honorable gentleman he's he said a
lot today he said a lot today but it's
clear that he isn't focused on the
serious issues that are confronting our
country we're strengthening our economy
he's backing the strikers we're
supporting people with energy bills he's
supporting the protesters and we're
tackling illegal migration he's opposing
every measure the British people want
real leadership on the serious Global
challenges we face and that's what
they'll get from this government
[Applause]
Mr Speaker 84 years ago today in Germany
hundreds of synagogues were destroyed
tourist goals were desecrated thousands
of Jewish businesses and and shops were
destroyed as well 91 Jewish people were
murdered and later 30 000 Jewish men
were sent to the concentration camps so
as we commemorate Christian let us
remember that it was started with
anti-jewish hatred it became
anti-Semitism and it's still prevalent
in society today so will my right on a
friend
condemn anti-Semitism in all its forms
but congratulate the Holocaust Survivors
who give their testimony year after year
and in particular congratulate the
Holocaust educational trust for the
brilliant work they do in making sure we
will never ever forget what happened in
the Holocaust
[Applause]
well can I thank my honorable friend for
his powerful question and his continued
work on this issue I completely agree
with them anti-Semitism has no place and
our society and we're taking a strong
lead in tackling it in all forms we
became the first country to adopt the
ihra definition of anti-semitism and the
government's independent advisor on
anti-Semitism regularly provides advice
to ministers on how best to tackle this
issue and can I join him as I know the
whole house will in praising the work of
those survivors who so bravely tell
their stories so that we might never
forget
SMP leader in Blackford
thank you Mr Speaker can I associate
myself with the remarks of the Prime
Minister for Armistice we remember those
that paid the ultimate sacrifice those
that continue to serve and we should
also remember the nuclear test veterans
who continue to seek Justice for
themselves
Mr Speaker
last night the Prime Minister suffered a
self-inflicted loss of its first cabinet
minister
a couple of weeks into the job it turns
out this prime minister's judgment is
every bit as bad as his predecessors
speaking of which we now know that his
former friend the former prime minister
plans to hand out seats in the House of
Lords to at least four Tory MPS
including the current Secretary of State
for Scotland so here's another test of
judgment for the new prime minister does
he think it right to keep a man in the
cabinet who's clearly far more
interested and in getting his hands on
an airline road than playing by the
rules of Scottish democracy
yeah
Mr Speaker I'm obviously not going to
comment on speculation around such lists
any list would of course follow the
normal procedures and processes that are
in place
[Music]
I'm afraid it's uh not speculation and
of course the Prime Minister clearly
doesn't get how corrupt this all looks
to people in Scotland because not only
do we have a UK government that denies
democracy we now have a secretary of
state that is Running Scared from it in
the middle of a Tory cost of living
crisis it's a Scotland offers is now to
be led by a baron and waiting abiding
his time until he can cash in on the
300-day job for Life In The House of
Lords he should be psyched from the
cabinet and that people have done
priests and Galloway should be given the
chance to sack the thorny in a
by-election the prime minister's
judgment is already interted if he has
any Integrity left will he now put a
stop to these two assessors stuffing the
House of Lords up with his Chronicles
[Music]
Mr Speaker what the Secretary of State
and I are jointly focused on is working
constructively with the Scottish
government to deliver for the people of
Scotland I'll be pleased to be meeting
the first Minister tomorrow because that
I think is what the people of Scotland
want to see
criminal gangs who are operating to
bring people into this country in small
boats an issue that directly affects my
constituents of folks on the hive are
openly using social media platforms to
recruit people to use their services
come on right honorable phones confirm
that the Online safety bill will require
social media platforms to take effective
action to remove this content and is it
also the intention of the government to
bring the bill back later this month
well can I thank my honorable friend for
his work in raising awareness of this
particular issue he is absolutely right
and I'm pleased to give him the
reassurance that the Online safety bill
will require platforms to remove and
limit the spread of illegal content and
activity online assisting illegal
immigration is listed as a priority bill
in the a priority offense in the bill
and we look forward to bringing it back
to the house in due course several
Roberts
the prime minister is struggling to
rebuild the Tories ruined economic
credibility after his predecessor
scorned the office for Budget
responsibility but in a Bloomberg
interview just last week his trade
secretary disputed obr forecasts that
trade will be 15 lower because of brexit
Britain's economic prospects are
worsened by being outside the world's
largest trading block that is a fact yep
so who does he agree with the obr or his
Tory minister
well well Mr Speaker one of the great
opportunities of brexit is our ability
to trade more with countries around the
world
[Applause]
[Music]
speak to many of the Welsh farmers who
are enjoying selling their lamb to the
new markets that we haven't opened up
for them that's what we'll get on and
deliver Millions
housing targets of placing greater and
greater pressure on councils to approve
development which damages our
environment when the Prime Minister came
to Finchley over the summer he said he
wanted to abolish those targets will he
use the leveling up a report stage to
bring forward government amendments to
do that
Mr Speaker the government is committed
to making home ownership a reality for a
new generation and we must build homes
in the right places where people want to
live and work but as the honorable lady
knows and as I said I want those
decisions to be taken locally with
greater say for local communities rather
than distant bureaucrats and my right
honorable friend the secretary of state
is happy to sit and meet with her to
discuss how best to make this a reality
yeah Mr Speaker does the Prime Minister
remember back in February when he was
Chancellor the exchecker when I I
informed him that Judah is incompetence
in that job the children in my
constituency would go to bed that night
with no food in their tummy and no heat
in their homes what is he now going to
do as prime minister to make sure that
in every community in our country
children aren't in that situation in
this hard winter ahead
well Mr Speaker the absolute best way to
ensure that children do not grow up in
poverty which is something that none of
us want to see is to ensure that they do
not grow up in a workless household and
the record under these governments is
that 700
000 fewer children are growing up in
workless households and that's because
conservative governments create jobs for
people Mr Speaker and that's the best
anti-poverty strategy that we have
Friday I visited a bridging hotel in my
constituency that is currently housing
77 Afghan refugees as local
organizations search for permanent
accommodation for them following the
success of operation pitting
many of the refugees I met held highly
skilled jobs back in Afghanistan
including a doctor International
athletes and government ministers
can the Prime Minister Shore the house
that our government will do more to
support these highly skilled individuals
to enter UK Workforce
well it's not nice to hear from my
honorable friend again this week and I
can reassure him that we are completely
committed to supporting Afghan refugees
into the employment opportunities here
in the UK the department for work and
pensions has a full program in place and
I can also tell him that our Refugee
leads Network brings together Refugee
organizations and DWP to connect those
refugees with employment opportunities
and I look forward to seeing the fruits
of that program with him in the near
future Bradshaw
yeah
five years ago the government belatedly
launched a review Into the security risk
posed by handing thousands of mainly
wealthy Russian and Chinese Nationals
so-called golden Visas so they could
live in Britain it also promised to
publish the results of that review why
hasn't it
[Music]
well Mr Mr Speaker
indeed end the the Visa that The
Honorable gentleman is Raising uh their
home office is currently conducting the
right way to replace that Visa with
something that is more sustainable going
forward and protects our security
interests I'll be happy to have the Home
Secretary write to him with an update on
that process
[Applause]
the UK has a Workforce shortage yet
millions of parents are unable to work
at Full Tilt and child care providers
are going belly up due to policies being
a maddenly expensive model of a mess
well my right honorable friend could
please confirm that after Decades of
ineffective tinkering and endless
policies that he will be the man to give
us proper Child Care reform
well Mr Speaker I'm pleased to say we've
announced ambitious new plans to improve
the cost the choice and the availability
of childcare to benefit hundreds of
thousands of parents across the country
this includes measures to increase the
number of children that we can look
after by each staff member and indeed
make it easier for people to become
child minders we'll respond to all of
these proposals in very short order
veneerables
thank you very much Mr Speaker I know
the Prime Minister has been very busy
failing to stand up to bullies but in
the real world
in real world schools and colleges
across the country looking after actual
children are struggling to make ends
meet one London head teacher has scrap
plans for Mental Health Counselors a
head teacher in Twickenham is no longer
filling teaching assistant vacancies
whilst another is axing school trips so
Mr Speaker will the Prime Minister give
pupils and parents a cast iron guarantee
that in next week's Autumn statement
there will be no real terms cuts to
school and college budgets
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we've significantly increased
funding going into schools over the next
two years but on top of that it was
important to this government to help
those children who left behind their
education opportunities during the
pandemic which is why we invested 5
billion pounds to helping those children
catch up including unveiling the most
Embrace most comprehensive program of
tutoring that this country has ever seen
and is closing the attainment Gap and
disproportionately benefiting
disadvantaged children and is something
that I know all colleagues will get
behind it through thank you Mr Speaker
despite a productive meeting with
immigration Minister yesterday the home
office continues to house over 400 Sun
Seekers in two neighboring hotels in my
constituency
to clear for my meetings with GPS and
Derbyshire police there's a huge influx
of people in such a small area is
putting local Services Under immense
strain before services in area wash hit
Breaking Point well my right humble
friend to commit to immediate reduction
in Asylum Seekers concentrated in one
place and will he intervene to set a
timetable for the permit closure of
accommodation centers at this location
well Mr Speaker let me give my honorable
friend my absolute uh cast iron
commitment that we want to get to grips
with this problem the best way to
resolve it is to stop criminal grounds
profiting from an illegal trade in human
lives and the unacceptable rise in
Channel Crossings which is putting
unsustainable pressure on our system and
local Services she has my reassurance at
the Home Secretary and I are working day
and night to resolve this problem not
just to end the use of expensive
contingency accommodation but for more
fundamental reform so that we can
finally get to grips with this issue
protect our borders and end illegal
migration
speaker Mr Speaker under the prime
minister's short Premiership he's had
one minute to reside and one that
urgently needs to be sacked can the
Prime Minister clarify to the house and
the rest of the country when the
scheduled program of Integrity
professionalism and accountability will
begin
[Applause]
Mr Speaker it's precisely because I want
a government characterized by Integrity
professionalism and accountability that
the right honorable gentleman was right
to resign and it's right that we have an
independent process that's the type of
government I will lead when situations
like this arise we will deal with them
properly and that's what we have done in
Russell thank you Mr Speaker
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was your egg
it's quite amazing when the ministers
come from his paws to get more cheers
come on
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you to my
colleagues and just just like the Prime
Minister I was very fortunate to join
the Royal British Legion in becoming a
poppy volunteer recently uh I joined uh
colleagues in in Abbott's Langley and I
was part of Les battersea's team and
this week I'll be joining Tony Griffiths
and his team in the tube award in
Watford Mr Speaker I I would like to ask
if the Prime Minister will join me in
thanking all of the poppy appeal
volunteers across the country including
my constituency for their work to ensure
that we always remember those
made the ultimate
and if the prime minister or perhaps the
minister for veterans will also visit
Watford to meet our heroic veterans who
we owe so much
and my honorable friend is a fantastic
Champion for Watford and it is a
pleasure to join him in thanking the
Royal British Legions poppy appeal
volunteers both in Watford and across
the country there is no greater
sacrifice than those who lay down their
lives in the service of our nation so
I'm proud as many others are to support
the poppy appeal and to honor our
veterans cold Turner if the prime
minister
or any member of his many households
became unwell
would he start ringing the GP sedra
eight o'clock each morning to not get an
appointment
would he go off to accident an emergency
and wait 12 hours to be seen
would he call an ambulance which
wouldn't come or would he use some of
his 750 million pounds
on and wealth to pay privately and see
somebody there and then
well
Mr Speaker I'm very grateful to let me
put on record my thanks to the Fantastic
Team at the friaridge hospital in
northallerton Who provided excellent
care to my family over the years uh but
the honorable Jensen is right to
highlight the issue of people waiting
unacceptably long for treatment that
they need that's why we put record
funding into the NHS to help with
backlogs and waiting times this winter
it's by the health secretary and the
chancellor are discussing how best to
deliver the reforms that we need because
I want to make sure that everyone gets
the care they need and we will continue
to invest in more doctors more nurses
and more Community scans so that we can
deliver exactly that thank you you Mr
Speaker
that pool is due to benefit from a 300
million pounds private sector-led
regeneration project which will deliver
thousands of new jobs for my
constituents over the years ahead to
deliver this ambitious new project we
need support with a 40 million pound
package of relocating the existing Court
complex which currently occupies the
site various secretaries and states have
been very supportive of the project so
far so is the prime minister able to
give me an update on when we can receive
some good news about how we can get this
project off the ground well I can I can
I join with the honorable member in
recognizing the importance of the
Blackhawk Central regeneration project
to the towns leveling up Ambitions I I
can tell him that my uh right on will
friend the Justice secretary and housing
secretary are in the process of
resolving this issue for him and how
best we can relocate the court complex
and and I can tell him he won't have to
wait very long for an update on the
plans
it is a critical time for our steel
industry hit by Massive energy costs and
low demand at a time when we need to
support our industry to adapt to be need
to build the green technologies that we
will need does the Prime Minister agree
that our Sovereign capability and our
national security is dependent on a
strong UK steel industry and if so will
the government not sit on its hands and
what is the prime minister's plan for
steel oh
Mr Speaker I'm proud of our track record
not only do we support one steel company
in South Wales during coronavirus that
needed our assistance which we were
pleased to do we also have provided over
2 billion pounds to support energy
intensive Industries including steel
with high energy bills and thanks to the
work of my colleagues remove the tariffs
and exporting steel to the United States
but she has my Assurance that we will
continue to support steel because we
recognize its importance to our economy
and to our communities up and down the
country
thank you Mr Speaker supermarkets such
as Morrisons are abusing their dominant
Market position on fuel charging up to
20p per liter more in bridport than
other towns in the region thus
preventing West Dorset residents from
benefiting from the very unusual
reduction in market price these days
will the Prime Minister agree to meet
with me to discuss what action can be
taken against these commercial Predators
who harm our local residents in this way
well Mr Speaker as Chancellor I was
pleased to cut Duty by 5p a liter the
biggest ever cut in fuel duty to help
motorists in our country but I recognize
the concerns The Honorable gentleman
raised that's why we asked the
competition and markets authority to
conduct an urgent review of the market
there are some actions to be considered
coming out of that review and I look
forward to meeting with him and working
with the CMA to explore its
recommendations in more detail Liam
Byrne thank you Mr Speaker tomorrow
across my constituency of Hodge hill
I'll be delivering food bank collection
crates because once more our food banks
are running out of food does the Prime
Minister understand that despair my
constituents feel that he is one of the
richest men in Britain is doing so
little
they don't like the truth Mr Speaker
does he understand the despair my
constituents feel that he is doing so
little for the poorest in Britain by
refusing to cancel the three billion
pound tax break for non-doms who profit
from our country but won't make our
country their home
well uh Mr Speaker I'm proud of mine
this government's track record and
supporting the most vulnerable in our
society
asks continue and
hearing from the gentleman who the first
person who reminded us what happens when
the economy gets crashed by labor
government that's no way to help people
we will build a strong economy that's
what enables us to support the most
vulnerable that's what enables us to
support strong Public Services
thank you Mr Speaker the British people
are reliant on our party and this
government to fulfill its promises on
leveling up not just up and down the
country but sideways too does my right
honorable friend agree with me that the
Felix Stone Heritage Freeport plan will
be judged as an historic failure unless
such a plan succeeds in leveling up a
deprived Ward that is in my constituency
and will my right handling friend join
me in clacton to kick start that plan
also Mr Speaker will my honorable friend
commit to coming to the tendering
Showcase currently in the Jubilee room
until 2 30.
that sounds like a very appealing
invitation Mr Speaker but I agree with
my honorable friend that leveling up has
to deliver for communities in every
corner of the United Kingdom including
in coastal communities in the South Mr
Speaker he knows I'm the champion of
Freeport and I look forward to working
with him to see how best we can realize
their benefits in his area that
completes prime minister's questions
those who wish to leave please do so
quietly
that is the end of pmq's Rishi sunak's
third prime minister's questions are not
an easy one for him facing tough
questions there from secure's Dharma
over the resignation of Gavin Williamson
uh just a few hours ago and we're going
to stay with uh proceedings in the
Commons now because the prime minister
is going to be making a statement on the
cop climate Summit that said he's not
yet on his feet so maybe we can chat to
our political editor Beth Rigby for a
few moments
oh he's he's got to he's got to his feet
we'll listen in and come back to you in
a second okay
sorry prime minister
sorry
it can't relate to the piano she didn't
ask a question we'll deal with it
afterwards prime minister thank you Mr
Speaker uh with permission I'd like to
make a statement on cop27 which I
attended in charmel Sheikh on Monday
when the United Kingdom took on the UK
presidency of cop just one third of the
global economy was committed to Net Zero
today that figure is 90 and the
reduction in global emissions pledged
during our presidency is now equivalent
to the entire annual emissions of
America now there is still a long way to
go to limit Global temperature rises to
1.5 degrees but but the historic Glasgow
climate pact kept that goal Within Reach
and the whole house I know will want to
join me in paying tribute to my right
honorable friend the member for Redding
West for his inspirational leadership as
top president
the question at the summit Mr Speaker
was where the countries would deliver on
their promises I'm pleased to say that
our nation will we have already cut our
Cobra emissions faster than anyone else
in the G7 and we will fulfill our
ambitious commitment to reduce emissions
by at least 68 by the end of the decade
now I know that some have feared Putin's
abhorrent war in Ukraine could distract
from Global efforts to tackle climate
change but I believe it should catalyze
them climate security and energy
security go hand in hand Putin's
contemptible manipulation of energy
prices has only reinforced the
importance of ending our dependence on
fossil fuels so we will make this
country a clean energy superpower we
will accelerate our transition to
Renewables which have already grown
fourfold as a proportion of electricity
Supply over the last decade we will
invest in building new nuclear power
stations for the first time since the
1990s
and by committing 30 billion pounds to
support our green Industrial Revolution
we will leverage up to a hundred billion
pounds of private investment to support
almost half a million high-wage
high-skilled green jobs Mr Speaker there
is also no solution to climate change
without protecting and restoring nature
so at cop27 the UK committed to 90
million pounds to the Congo Basin as
part of one and a half billion pounds
we're investing in protecting the
world's forests and I co-hosted the
first meeting of our forest and climate
leaders partnership which will deliver
on the historic commitment to Halt and
reverse Forest loss and land degradation
by 2030.
now Central to all our efforts is
keeping our promises on climate Finance
so the UK is delivering on our
commitment of 11.6 billion pounds and to
support the most vulnerable who are
experiencing the worst impacts of
climate change we will triple our
funding on adaptation to reach one and a
half billion pounds a year in 2025.
in Glasgow the UK pioneered a new Global
approach using Aid funding to unlock
billions of pounds of private Finance
for new green infrastructure
so I was delighted to join president
ramaphosa to Mark the publication of his
investment plan which delivers on this
new model South Africa will benefit from
cheaper cleaner power cutting emissions
while simultaneously creating new green
jobs for his people
and we will look to support other
International Partners in taking a
similar approach we also made further
commitments to support clean power in
developing countries this included
investing a further 65 million pounds in
commercializing Innovative clean
Technologies and working with the
private sector to deliver a rust of
graft of green investment projects in
Kenya now Mr Speaker the summit also
allowed me to meet many of my
counterparts for the first time
with Egyptian president
with the Egyptian president I raised the
case of the British Egyptian citizen
Allah Abdel fattah and I know the whole
house will share my deep concern about
his case which grows more Urgent by the
day
and we will continue to press the
Egyptian government to resolve this
situation we want to see Allah freed and
reunited with his family as soon as
possible
with President macron we discussed our
shared determination to crack down on
criminal smuggling gangs and I also
discussed illegal migration with other
European leaders too we are all facing
the same share Challenge and we agreed
to solve it together
and finally I had good meetings with the
new prime minister of Italy the German
Chancellor the president of the EU the
president of Israel and the leaders of
UAE Kenya and Norway as well as the UN
Secretary General
in all of these discussions the United
Kingdom is acting with our friends to
stand up for our values around the world
to deliver stability and security at
home
tackling climate change and securing our
energy Independence is Central to these
objectives
so even though we may now have handed
over the presidency of cop the United
Kingdom will proudly continue to lead
the global effort to deliver Net Zero
because this is the way to ensure the
security and prosperity of our country
for today and generations to come and I
commend this statement to the house call
the leader of the opposition Pier
Starman
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker can I thank the
Prime Minister for advanced copy of his
statement and can I start by raising the
case of Allah abdul-fatah as the Prime
Minister knows and has said he's a
British citizen jailed for the crime of
posting on social media and being
imprisoned in Egypt for most of the last
nine years he's been on hunger strike
for the last six months now the Prime
Minister just said that he raised it
with President CeCe could he tell us
what progress he made in securing
Allah's release
Mr Speaker it's right that the Prime
Minister eventually went to cop27.
remember the stakes the world is heading
for 2.8 degrees of warming that's Mass
flooding habitats destroyed Untold
damage to lives and livelihoods we must
prevent that for security for the public
finances and for the next generation and
that's why it was inexplicable that he
had to be dragged Kicking and Screaming
to even get on the plane Britain should
be leading on the world stage helping
the world confront the greatest
challenge of our time but his snub one
of the first decisions of his
Premiership was a terrible error of
judgment and sent a clear message that
if you're looking for leadership from
this prime minister look elsewhere but
if you want to get this Primus to go
somewhere get the right on board member
for Uxbridge first get him to come along
then the Prime Minister will follow
and his reluctance is so bizarre because
climate change is not just a once in a
generation responsibility it's also a
once in a generation opportunity an
opportunity to lower energy bills for
good an opportunity to ensure Britain's
security is never again at the mercy of
tyrants like Putin an opportunity to
create millions of jobs and break out of
the Tory cycle of low growth and high
taxes opportunities he's passing by
the Prime Minister said in his speech
that cop 27 that we need to act faster
on Renewables
so why is he the roadblock at home as he
was flying to Egypt his Minister was
reaffirming the ban on onshore wind the
cheapest cleanest form of power that we
have
the Prime Minister also said at [ __ ] 27
that he realizes the importance of
ending our dependence on fossil fuels
but he's inserted a massive oil and gas
giveaway when labor forced him into a
windfall tax
taxpayers cash handed over for digging
up fossil fuels
shall have made 26 billion pounds in
profit so far this year but not a penny
paid on windfall taxes he
left them off the hook and what about
the industries of the future
manufacturers of batteries for cars in
Britain struggling green hydrogen
producers struggling yet in other
countries these industries are taking
off
jobs going abroad because we've got no
industrial strategy here at home yeah
and as he said at cop 27 it was right to
honor our promises to developing
countries
why is he cutting the aid budget it's
always the same message do as I say not
as I do and because of that it will
always fall on deaf ears
Mr Speaker it's time for a fresh start a
labor government would make Britain the
first major economy to reach a hundred
percent clean Power by 2030. that would
cut Bill strengthen our energy security
create jobs and make Britain a clean
energy superpower and our green
Prosperity plan would establish GB
energy a publicly owned Energy company
to invest in the Technologies and the
jobs of the future here in the UK
as we attempt this endeavor we have a
fair wind at our back not just the
Ingenuity the Brilliance of people and
businesses in this country but the
natural resources of our island nation
wealth lies in our season in our skies
and it's an act of national self-harm
not to prioritize them over expensive
gas
that is the choice that the next general
election whenever it comes more of the
same with the Tories or a fairer Greener
future with labor
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker and uh you know the
honorable gentleman raised at the matter
of my attendance at cop I just would
gently point out to him that labor Prime
Ministers failed to attend I think 12 of
the 13 cops held during their time in
office
as as Chancellor as Chancellor I hosted
the finance day on cop last year where
we had Landmark agreements to rewire the
financial system to unlock the trillions
of dollars we need in private Finance to
flow to help us with the transition it's
a record I am proud of and it's a record
by the way that is recognized
internationally around the world to just
deal with his brief substantive
questions he asked about Renewable Power
well Mr Speaker 40 of our electricity
now comes for Renewable Power is up
four-fold since 2010 and this what do we
inherit a labor government that believed
there was no economic case for new
nuclear power Mr Speaker he talked about
oil and gas we talked he talked about
oil and gas again he needs to live in
the real world Mr Speaker
oil and gas are going to be a part of
our Energy Mix in the transition for the
several years ahead and it's simply upon
the sky to pretend otherwise the
independent committee on climate change
has even recognized that and the carbon
footprint of having homegrown gas is
half the footprint of importing it from
abroad so it's a sensible thing to do
but look Mr Speaker our plan is the
right pound it's realistic it's credible
it's delivering for the British people
as well as delivering on our climate
adjustments uh his own I think his own
Shadow Chief secretary decided his
climate plan as quote unquote a
borrowing plan and we know where that
leads us Mr Speaker it's not the right
thing for the British people
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I know the British people
trust me to manage the economy they
won't trust the labor party
he might be focused he might be focused
in reparations around the world we're
focused on creating a strong economy
here at home and that's what we're doing
Theresa May thank you uh thank you Mr
Speaker can I welcome my right honorable
friends statement and also welcome the
continued commitment that he and the
government are showing to Net Zero by
2050 to tackling climate change he's
absolutely right to talk about the
creation of high-skilled high-wage green
jobs as we green our economy but people
need to have the training and the skills
and education to be able to take on
those jobs what are the government's
plans in relation to Education and
Training for green skills
my rival friend is is absolutely right
and I thank her for her warm comments uh
I point her to our record investment in
apprenticeships in particular but also
to the new lifelong learning entitlement
which acknowledges that people will have
to retrain at any point during their
life to take advantage of the new
economic opportunities that are coming
our way and I'm pleased that we'll be
rolling out that program over the coming
years
thank you Mr Speaker can I thank the
Prime Minister for advanced sake of his
statement and let me also welcome the
prime minister's last minute change of
heart to actually attend Corp 27 but I'm
afraid whether he likes it or not his
initial Institute telling him not to
attend will be wrong remembered and
rightly remembered it means you know
he's a major job in convincing people
that he is truly committed to the
challenge of climate change and of
course that that commitment starts with
our own domestic targets but it is vital
that our Collective commitment also
extends to those in the global South
Nations and peoples are being damaged
the most by a climate crisis that they
have contributed the least to these are
the poorest people on this planet and
they always seem to be paying the
highest price that is why it is so right
and so necessary that loss and damage
was on the formal Co-op agenda for the
very first time I'm proud to say that
through the leadership of our first
Minister Scotland has become the first
developed Nation to pledge Finance
address loss and damage and our country
is now committed to a total of seven
million pounds a small sum and a scale
of what is needed but a powerful message
to larger Nations we need to follow that
lead because we don't need to wait for
consensus and a decision that come on we
can start funding loss and damage
programs straight away so can I ask the
Prime Minister if he will guarantee that
UK overseas aid earmarked for climate
finance will be spent within the
five-year time frame as originally
promised and can he also guarantee that
the total Aid budget won't be slashed
further than the Autumn statement next
week and finally in terms of the new
prime minister's domestic targets and
climates well he honor that promises
made to the northeast of Scotland in
carbon capture and storage will I commit
to taking the Scottish cluster off the
government's Reserve list and fund it
right now
well Mr Speaker I'm actually pleased
that it was the UK that established a
New Glasgow Dialogue on loss and damage
to discuss arrangements for funding
activities to avert minimize and address
loss and damage and those conversations
are ongoing with regard to our
International climate Finance pledge as
I said we remain committed to the 11.6
billion it is Our intention to deliver
it over the time frame that was
originally envisaged and with regard to
targets again it should be a source of
enormous Pride for everyone in this
house that we have decarbonized in this
country faster than any other G7 country
and our targets are among the most
ambitious in the world and we have a
credible plan to get on and deliver them
speaker can I congratulate my right on
Royal friend for his Crystal Clear
commitment both in Sharm El Sheikh and
in this chamber here today to delivering
Net Zero Britain there is no doubt about
that under his prime ministership now
we're no longer have the presidency of
kov uh which has been acting as a
forcing mechanism across the government
how can you clarify how he intends that
his government uh will deliver our
ambitious nationally determined
contribution to reduce emissions
um across the disparate strands of
government government departments
well my uh mindful friend makes an
excellent point and I can assure him
that though though we are no longer
formerly presidents of cop our
leadership on this issue internationally
will not waver and he has my commitment
on that and and I personally will drive
this through government in conjunction
with the Secretary of State for business
and energy indeed and with our climate
change Minister but this is something Mr
Speaker that pervades all aspects of
government now and that's what we have
to change our thinking on this it's not
the work of any one department or any
one Minister if we're going to make this
commitment work we're going to all have
to play our part
John Trickett very much and given the
scale of what's about to happen to our
planet every single one of us must do
what we can to alleviate the problems
which we're facing but one percent the
one percent richest people on our planet
are responsible for the same amount of
global emissions as the poor is 50
percent
does the Prime Minister accept that
unless we tackle the issues of social
justice we will not resolve the problems
of climate change and what's he
comfortable that one of the worst
polluters in the planet Coca-Cola
sponsored the recent meeting of cop
Mr Speaker as we've been discussing I
believe we do have a moral obligation to
help those countries with the transition
to Net Zero and I'm proud to say that we
are playing our part in doing that and
it was great at cop to sit down with
leaders from many of those Emerging
Market countries that are benefiting
from the investments from our country to
help them with the transition and they
recognize the leadership role that we
are playing right Clark thank you very
much Mr Deputy speaker we need to create
jobs and prosperity as we transition to
Net Zero and in Battery Technology we're
World leading in the research but we
need to manufacture batteries here now
given the concerning news about British
votes will the Prime Minister and his
colleagues commission an urgent review
of how we can deliver the gigafactories
that are necessary in this country in
the short term to make sure that we have
a continuing vibrant car manufacturing
industry uh well I thank my honorable
friend and I'm pleased to say I think it
may have been his idea that we created
the Faraday battery challenge but it was
pleased that I was pleased to support
that as Chancellor with 200 million
pounds of funding he's right about the
importance of building a domestic
gigafactory capability I was pleased
with the announcement from Envision and
Nissan in Sunderland there's more in the
pipeline and we have the automotive
transformation fund available to support
those projects to build the vibrant
ecosystem that he and I both want to see
uh Davey this is Debbie speaker can I
welcome what the Prime Minister said at
cop that tackling climate change goes
hand in hand with luring energy bills
improving our energy security and
hurting Putin in his illegal war in
Ukraine
however I'm alarmed at home the Prime
Minister has banned onshore wind one of
the cheapest most popular forms of
renewable energy so will the Prime
Minister confirm whether his priority is
cutting people's energy bills improving
Britain's insecurity and tackling global
climate change or keeping it the
dinosaurs on his back benches happy why
won't he back why won't he get rid of
the ban on onshore wind
Mr Speaker it started so well
um
we are committed to reducing people's
bills and to having more forms of
renewable energy and our track record on
this is superb four times more than in
2010 the amount of renewable energy zero
carbon energy now accounts uh for all
half of our electricity needs and we
oppose to do more offshore wind is a
thing we are focusing on along with
nuclear and we are now a world leader in
offshore wind and it's providing cheap
forms of electricity and energy for
households up and down the country and
alongside nuclear That's How we'll
transition to to a cleaner grid it was
great thank you Mr Deputy speaker can I
thank my right all your friends for
getting our environmental strategies
back on track we clearly have a major
issue not simply around carbon but also
about the loss of biodiversity both on
land and at Sea and I welcome what he
says about our support for the Congo
Basin we have in a month's time another
crucial Summit in Montreal the CBD
Summit where further decisions will be
taken about how we tackle the loss of
biodiversity internationally can I ask
him to ensure the United Kingdom plays
the fullest possible part in those
discussions and a leadership role in
tackling this issue going forward
you know my vulnerable friend is is
absolutely right and there were very
many moving uh statements from leaders
across the globe at cop on this
particular topic and it's something that
we are I can't confirm to him we are
widely acknowledged around the world to
be a leader on for putting this on the
agenda last year in Glasgow uh the
Secretary of State for the environment
will be attending that that cop in
Montreal and also our world-leading
environment act commits us to reducing
the decline in biodiversity
biodiversity and species loss and I look
forward to working with him to deliver
on it
Sarah champion thank you Mr Deputy
speaker and prime minister of course I
welcome any investment to the global
South to mitigate against the horrific
damages of global climate change but is
this new money is it coming out of the
existing odor budget what's being cut if
it is coming out of the existing odor
budget and also as Chancellor you made
Savage cuts to climate mitigation
programs are you going to be replacing
those
Mr Speaker asked Chancellor yes I did
make difficult decisions to ensure that
our public finances were on a
sustainable trajectory that's not
something that I'm going to shine away
from because I think we've all seen what
happens when the government doesn't
command the confidence of the
international markets when it comes to
borrowing and debt issues and I thought
in that context it was reasonable to
temporarily reduce our odor budget until
our public finances are in a better
place and that is a commitment that I
stand by but within we are remaining
committed to the 11.6 billion pounds in
international climate finance that we
committed at time and those
announcements have come from that budget
and it's very welcome that we're able to
continue delivering that even though
we're facing some other difficult
decisions on to other topics Theresa
Villas
uh the Prime Minister has emphasized the
very substantial investment being made
in climate related measures both for
home and overseas but will he share with
me reservations about the idea of
spending trillions more pounds on
so-called reparations payments as
advocated by the opposition at a time
when the public finances are already
quite right
my right honorable friend is is
absolutely right that is not the right
approach and it's worrying to hear the
members of the party opposite suggesting
that it is what we are doing is
fulfilling our obligations to help those
Emerging Markets transition to a cleaner
future and we're doing that in a way
that supports them but also supports
British companies who are able to
provide those Investments and create
jobs here at home as well
Jeremy corbyn thank you Mr Deputy
speaker I'm grateful for my continued
rent-free tenancy in the prime
minister's head but if in future you
could just let me know when he intends
to speak about me that would be helpful
that's the norm in the house
could I ask him if he would take this
opportunity to welcome the election of
President Lula in Brazil and his
commitment to both social justice and
environmental justice and confirm what
the previous prime minister told this
house that no British bank or financial
institution or company will henceforce
be allowed to invest in fossil fuel
extraction anywhere in the world as part
of our contribution to Bringing about
Net Zero globally
uh well I I Thank The Honorable
gentleman for his question if he could
ask the leader of the opposition maybe
to give me advanced sight of his
questions I'll be happy to then let him
know if I uh if I need to bring him up
on questions of security uh but look I
agree with him on the importance I agree
with him on the importance of ending
international finance for coal-fired
power plants it was a landmark agreement
that the cop president and the UK
presidency achieved at Corp uh 90 other
countries have signed up to it at a
minimum and it's key I'm Keen to make
sure that we deliver on those
commitments and we push them through the
International Financial system
you forward thank you Mr Speaker my
Essex constituents absolutely get the
impact of climate change because they
saw it firsthand in those awful fires
last summer many of them also get that
unless we help other countries to
mitigate and adapt climate change we
will see even more unsustainable
migration and that will impact us at
home so it's great that that might write
a little friend has reconfirmed our
commitment to the investment amounts
that we promised in Glasgow that he has
reconfirmed our commitment to deliver
those on time and can he confirm that we
will continue to work with other
countries to make sure those Investments
are made on time yeah can I can I thank
my or just dip out of the commons there
uh prime minister rishi's soon act
taking questions following his statement
on cop but of course preceding that was
a rather combative prime minister's
questions uh the focus the resignation
of Sir Gavin Williamson uh last night
and we will have more on that at the top
of the hour do stay with us